head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard charts would
you vote for Trump if he chose Nikki as
VP and would you guys vote for Trump
well that's the question that I asked
you specifically I I would not only not
vote for that ticket I would I would
Advocate against it as strongly as I
could wow wow yeah I that's just that's
just point I mean here's someone who's
actively opposed to the interest of the
country I grew up in who endorsed the
BLM riots and who is not is is not left
but is neoliberal in the darkest most
speaking of nihilist nihilistic way and
has no real popular support is like is a
creature of the oligarch so yeah that
would be that would be reason to oppose
the ticket even Trump Haley is a nogo
Nikki Haley he would get assassinated
immediately if that were the case yeah
and by the way I just can't imagine a
world where that could happen that would
be so crazy I mean anything could happen
of course but picking Nikki Haley um
who's utterly treacherous and utterly
dismissive of like the interests of
Americans yeah it's a no-o for me uh but
it's a yes for Black Rock and State
Street that really do love her but but
who vard but but I want to turn the
question to to everyone here and just
really quickly who would you guys like
to see as Trump's VP as of course he
knows what he's doing vice president I I
have I know what they think I have the
straw pole results but before the straw
pole results let's just go let's go
around who who do you want to see as VP
I'm a big fan of a ramaswami
Charlie I um I'm sitting next who I
think should be vice president me I mean
I agree with you I'd vote for
that I I I think Tucker makes a lot of
sense for vice president I've said it
publicly I'll say it privately I
mean I mean I but the case I I kind of
like the Vue I think he's one of those
people who everyone beats up on vake for
being he's a phony and all this stuff I
don't know I I've covered a lot of
campaigns going back to 1992 and I've
noticed this thing in many candidates
and I noticed it in him the proc the
process of running for president and
speaking three times a day and having
people throw hostile questions in your
face causes you to change they all
change during this campaigns like for
real inside and I feel like V's
positions have gotten much more sincere
since the beginning of this like he I
watch him with Nikki Hal and I'm like
this is a guy who's very offended by her
views like for real he's not attacking
her cuz she's a woman he's attack
because he actually thinks her views are
terrible for the country he lives in and
I love that mhm so is that is that a no
you're not going to Tim no I mean it's
like the weather I can't control that I
don't think I'd be that great at it well
who do you want to see as VP so I I I
think you know we we we we talked a bit
about this for a long time and often
have entertained VI ramaswami but then
when Trump Carlson popped up we all kind
of lit up like that would be amazing but
I think it's I think it's because when
we were talking about Dan santis so long
ago it was cuz we were looking for
someone who was less the Wild Card Trump
is a very strong personality and we were
looking for something that was someone
that would be a stabilizing Force vake
is is very much like that uh Ron I think
his campaign has kind of uh been very
poorly run I'm trying to be nice here
and uh then we look to Tucker Carlson
Tucker you've got your finger on the PSE
probably better than anybody else in in
the country well that's I don't know
about that but I I do care about the
country I know the country pretty well
very well very well actually it's like
the one thing I know a lot about and I I
think that kind of disqualifies me right
there but can I just ask a question
since you all are so on the internet and
like I'm not that much um you really get
the sense that Ronda santis who I liked
as Governor uh the people who represent
him online are the nastiest the
stupidest and the most zero some people
I've ever seen in my life and I don't
think that reflects him but it's like
this is kind of small ball and by the
way these purported conservatives Ron
desant has changed his View and I like
him okay I think he's been a good
Governor I just want to be clear about
that I know him personally I like him
but his donor Ken Griffin told him to
change his view on Ukraine from it's a
regional conflict we shouldn't get
involved in to it's a super important
thing we should send more money one
donor got him to change his View and all
these so-called conservatives are
supporting that like it's the most
important thing ever like who are these
people and what is their problem like
what is going on with them it it does
reflect on Ron because Ron should have
fired the people running his campaign a
long time ago uh look I I respect that
he wanted to launch his campaign on X on
Twitter space time and it and it failed
miserably this is a mistake and now
you've got uh look I know a lot of
people groan but a lot of people laugh
the high heels you know boot Scandal I
mean who's giving this guy advice and
why does he keep taking it cuz I will
say it I will say it politically and and
policy wise we love Ronda santis he's
done an amazing job but his campaign is
a train wreck yeah well and and so I I
can speak to this just having
experienced some of the um you know uh
so you're suppor online that's literally
what I'm saying of course thank you um
no so with the the D Santa situation
again like I know people who work for
his campaign who are are good people who
I really like but that said I have not
gotten more um like Angry Petty push
back from anons online ever for pushing
back against any politician than I have
when I've made comments about disantis
that were pretty benign I remember when
he was uh announcing his campaign one
thing I said is look you know when I see
Trump tear DeSantis uh apart or make fun
of him it doesn't Thrill Me The Way him
destroying Jeb Bush thrilled me because
I think if both Trump and DeSantis are
successful that's good for the
Republican party and it's a shame that
they've been pitted against one another
age yeah and and I said that and then I
said here's the reality about D santis I
should have been agreeing with
everything he was saying in his his
campaign speech when he first announced
and I was bored to tears and they need
to get somebody to help him with his
delivery so he can be more charismatic
because that matters to people I think
that's a pretty benign piece of
constructive criticism and I was just
flooded with angry replies from his
followers and it was so strange to me
because I've said far harsher things
about other Republican candidates and I
have not experienced even a small
fraction of the push back they're matter
at you than Joe Biden I don't get what
is that and like and I by the way as
someone who who is uh generally liked
Trump I've made fun of and pushed back
against Trump too and my fans who really
like Trump enjoyed it they thought it
was funnier they agreed I made fun of
trump all the time that's okay he's a
person no one is God okay lighten up a
little bit my my conspiracy theory is
that the people online are actually
Trump supporters masquerading as disant
supporters to just make everybody hate
them I'm like it's the only explanation
I mean come on at a certain point you
have to realize you to like we're
talking about his campaign staff and and
his and his high level staff at a
certain point you have to realize what
you're doing is failing I mean polls are
going down he's being beaten by Nikki
Haley in the polls if you want to trust
the polls I'm like at a certain point do
what stop you're it's not working but
they keep doing the exact same thing but
but I'll tell you I had a realization
the other day because I saw this tweet
from Laura lomer uh which purportedly
came from Christina Pasha but it
appeared to be fake and I tweeted no
there's no way this can be real
Christina Pasha then retweeted a fake
version supposedly coming from Laura
lummer now this at this point it's
clearly fake because it was a
manipulation on what Laura had posted so
I call that out saying these people are
the scumbags they camea they claim the
Trump people are and I get this push
back where they say you see to have
ignored the fact the Trump campaign did
this first whoa whoa whoa I figured it
out Laura ler is not the Trump campaign
she's Trump's biggest fan she does a lot
of work in support of trump but she is
outside of the campaign and she is not
on the same level as Trump's campaign
staff and press secretary Christina Pasa
for Ronda santis is his second in
command who is acting on the internet as
though she is on the same level as Laura
lomer is despite Laura not being part of
Trump's campaign so and I'm saying this
not to be disrespectful to anybody what
I'm saying is if you are running a
president presidential campaign but you
think your path to Victory is to argue
with fans of your opponent online you
have put yourself way below the
standards of of that Governor you're
representating yeah one thing I want to
point out that might be a possible uh
explanatory Factor here the the great
and insightful Orin McIntyre said this
so I'll give him credit but the disantis
campaign has effectively become a
shelling point for all of the elements
within the Republican party that just
hated Trump so even though disantis has
great policies because they see it as a
very us verse him type of thing a lot of
people in the Republican party who we
would agree shouldn't have a place in it
have migrated to his campaign and I
don't think they've advised them well I
think that it is very clear that there
is some ineptitude going around in in
the S as a campaign but that you brought
up Tim that there's some sort of
malfeasance that people are in there
manipulating the scenes like we have ai
that could just be twisting people's
thoughts about danas constantly with
comments with retweets AI could be
retweeting other AIS that are or even
machine learning algorithms that are
like making him look really bad on
purpose or vice versa I mean it's let's
or he has autism but no no but let's get
into this let's get into this um one of
the scariest things I think we're seeing
now is the potential for what I mean
Steve Ben talks about this quite quite a
bit The Singularity we are getting uh
well let me start from the beginning
there's something called Dead internet
Theory Tu you have you ever heard of
this no' be the last to know this is
this it's an idea that he's flexing that
he goes outside by the way he's like you
guys look pal enough can you internet
questions for me so dead iner Theory uh
believes that around 2016 is when we saw
a shift from real people on the internet
into AI Bots and sock puppets sock
puppets are you know one person will run
50 accounts to try and manipulate public
opinion and uh maybe maybe Elon Musk is
working very hard to get bots off of X
to try and create a genuine conversation
but as we're now to the point where we
have these large language models and a
lot of them especially grock now grock
is new the potential that you are not
even talking to a person when you're
debating online is is nearing 100% I'm
curious what your thoughts are on this
on this AI future and with these fears
in
mind well I mean it's hard to sort of
ignore the Instinct that like we're
approaching something horrible and final
I mean I don't understand how you and
could in good conscious build something
like AI it's so Tower of Babel it's so
transparently Genesis 11 it's so
transparently insane and of course we
now reports that the people building it
or worshiping it like a god which
obviously it is and um
it that feels to me like the craziest
most Reckless thing people have ever
done and I think the chance that that
ends in tears is 100% V little G and so
but also it's like technological
progress I don't know we've had quite a
bit of it and this country's become much
worse in every measurable way since I
was a child with much less technological
progress so and I'm sorry I know there
we have tech people I have friends who
are professional technologists and
they're very excited about technology
but where's the evidence that it's a
good thing bingo I think I mean where's
the evidence even the public health has
declined they used to say well at least
we'll cure cancer okay but that's not
happening people are getting we have
more cancer actually more obesity more
Su exactly so where just just show me
the place where technology in the last
20 years has made people happier I think
and I don't think there is such a place
so maybe we should rethink our core
assumptions about technology I agree but
I do think we have serious cultural
problems and I wonder if perhaps the
argument is a culture will be destroyed
through uh Tech technology in this way
particularly the communications
technology it starts with the printing
press which we say was great then the
radio it was fantastic then television
oh how awesome and now the Internet it's
changed everything but it does seem like
it's becoming noise and static and pure
chaos from it I'm wondering if it is an
impossible solution or if we've just not
found the solution it's a neutral Force
it's just like the atom bomb is neutral
if it's in the hands of evil it will be
used for
evil do you really think that because
here solve this mystery for me um
creativity pretty much died in the West
in August of 1945 when we bombed
Hiroshima and then Nagasaki so I don't
know I maybe I'm the only person who's
interested in this but the the death of
creativity in the United States is very
jarring to me that's true in literature
name three great novels written since
1945 in English oh you can't name 10
great Public Works projects since 1945
oh not possible something changed
fundamentally since we dropped that bomb
and I don't think I'm imagining it and
by the way if you have counter evidence
to wreck my theories please give it to
me but I do think something about the
Godlike powers of nuclear weapons
convince people they are God I think
there may be some spiritual force in
effect there but whatever it is that
moment changed this country in the
entire West forever and diminished it
forever and I grew up defending the
bombing of Japan with the atomic weapons
because oh you know we couldn't deal
with an invasion or whatever and now I'm
thinking in what way how insane was I to
defend dropping a nuclear bomb on people
if you find yourself defending that
you're a freak but but but I'm wondering
if it's it's not the nuclear bombs but
television the expansion of Television
uh I've I've often half joked that the
'90s was the last decade and I think
it's probably due to the internet the
decentralization of of communications
through the internet results in no
cohesive visible culture in this country
you look at the 40s 50s 607s you see a
unique culture that exists in America of
course after the '90s with the explosion
of the internet now
I I got to tell you we went to the mall
a couple days ago and this it really
does blow my mind that I see a Hot Topic
and I guarantee you Jack Skellington is
in is in the window that's a 30-year-old
movie still being sold to kids who have
no idea what it is I there's a viral Tik
Tok where a young woman's wearing a
Nirvana shirt and just I don't even know
what this is I just buy it anyway it is
it's almost like television around that
era does something to creativity by
homogenizing everything but we don't
understand this I mean look the creative
force is the life force and by the way
it's closely related to the the sex
impulse which ultimately is a creative
Force to create new people that's
exactly right so if you see a decline in
or a death of the creative Force what
you're looking at is death of the
culture Andor society and there is no
question movies are just one
manifestation of it we have seen the
death of the creative impulse in the
west and that is like an emergency a
tragedy a history changing event and
it's never acknowledged as you were
saying that I it clicked for me it's
contra
cves it is it is the it is the
development of reliable and effective
methods of artificial contraceptives and
their legalization across the
country no it's true no it's a reality
because the most well and this is
something all Christians believed a
hundred years ago in in Prior the one of
the most intimate and productive
literally productive things human beings
do together you are collaborating with
God in the creation of new human persons
whose Souls will last longer than all of
the stars in the universe and we took
that and we turned it into playtime we
said this is for fun this is for feeling
good this is not about making things and
we thought that wouldn't affect our
psychology thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time